Oksana proscenko has been searching for
her father since the Battle of bucha
ended in March Sergey persenko left
their home to check on a friend
the family fled to Poland during the
Russian occupation of the town and
returned to Ukraine to see his car
riddled with bullet holes
returning here to see his car all shut
up they're at it struck me
um
job one neighbor told her he had been
shot by Russian troops others said he
died in shelling but Oksana believes he
might be in Russian custody
I can't forgive these people
I would beg them to return my father I
would do anything to get him back
I would beg them to give back my dad I
would do anything to have him back alive
Ukrainian authorities social media sites
and the Red Cross have been flooded with
inquiries about missing people we're
talking about several thousands of
families who are still
searching for their loved ones who want
to hear about their loved ones know
their whereabouts know their faith since
March the red cross's Central tracing
Bureau has fielded calls from 24
000 people looking for friends or
relatives lost in Ukraine
some are buried in numbered graves in
bucha oksana's Hometown some might be in
Russian captivity others are simply
missing with the Russian troops gone in
a sense of normality returning sometimes
Oksana says she just wants to forget
she said it was not the first I don't
want to believe that all of this
happened I just want to fall asleep and
wake up and realize that none of this
never happened it's not real
nothing will feel normal Oksana says
until her father has returned to her or
found and buried
John hendren Al Jazeera butcher Ukraine